hey everybody what's going on vlay here
and i'm backstage with the lovely grace
potter
clap everybody clap come on
guys
stuffy audience in here you have an
awesome voice amazing soulful i think
it's been described as mine um what are
some vocal warm-ups you do do you have
specifics oh yeah every day before you
get going one good warm-up is um rubber
baby buggy bumpers rubber wait say that
slow rubber baby buggy bumpers rubber
baby but rubber rubber
baby
bumpers you just see that a thousand
times you just kind of get it it just
like loosens it rubber baby and then you
can also just go
[Applause]
all right let's do it together ready
yeah
[Applause]
and you just keep going higher and
higher
you just keep going until you spin on me
you're going to be on vh1 storytellers
yes is there anything too hot for vh1
yeah oh yeah really actually they played
a really funny joke on the head of our
record company and they sent him what
what they said well here's the promo and
there's this one thing i said there was
this point where i had like a frog in my
throat you didn't do your
no i obviously hadn't warmed up enough
right it was like a really serious song
and in the middle of the series song i
was like oh this is what i get for
giving [ __ ] before i go on stage
and what they did was they cut it into
like a really pro looking vh1 promo and
sent it to the head of my record company
they were like what do you think about
this for the lead-off promo
that's amazing all right cool so we got
some questions from the old twitter
you're huge on twitter i know at grace
potter at grace poppy you're not that
huge i have like you know it's like 50
some months don't let's not don't do
that how many followers do you have
a lot i'll tell you i actually check it
a
lot
10 043 and i'm like bleeding slowly so
it's like every time i make a tweet i
lose like three followers it's true it's
really true you know pictures
just put some kittens up there
i should probably stop the naked
pictures
angel and white asks uh what is your
favorite song off the lion the beast and
the beat to play live oh man that's so
hard right now it's the lion the beast
the beast that song is it's an epic
thing it's got pieces of it it's got a
whole it's got movements like i said
there's airplane landings there's like a
lot of this now like yeah starting to
learn the songs
because the crowd is just getting to
know the new music that's great if they
can already figure out that it's
fist-pumping time about halfway through
it's like it's really exciting to get
people jumping up and down at mystic
burrito says what's your favorite cheese
oh well that's easy come on mr burrito
it's a cabot habanero it's the spiciest
most amazing cheese in the world cabot
cheddar habanero are you a big cheese
person major holy crap because you just
rolled that right up oh it's easy oh my
god but i also love like jasper hill
farm i mean i'm from vermont right
cheese is a big thing absolutely but we
actually work with cabot creamery oh my
god yeah we had a cabinet bus for a
while we had like a cheese bus that
sounds like the best business it was
amazing and they sent us on the road
with cheese and no one took a crap for
like three months
uh last question angelica lopez said
says has your hair grown back you burned
a good piece of it off at a rock star's
hou
what happened
that's what this tweet says and tweets
are never wrong obviously listen they're
almost right though i did burn my hair
off it was bad it was really really
really bad bald spot right oh my god and
it was um and so i had these bangs
covering it up and then everyone started
getting bangs so i was like
yeah exactly you're a trendsetter all
right grace potter everybody the album
the new album the lion the beast the
beat is out now itunes and stores uh get
it uh gracepotter.com at gracepotter on
twitter uh veach1 storytellers what else
what else can we plug uh
grace potter you rock you rock thank you
so much good talk see you guys next time
[Music]